so today i want to tell you that almost
all integers contain the digit 3.
so the integers are the whole numbers
so i'm saying that almost all whole
numbers contain the digit 3.
it sounds strange doesn't it yeah
because you i can think of infinitely
many numbers that contain a three okay
i've got three
333 333
and so on right i can think of
infinitely many numbers that don't
contain a three
seven
seventy seven seven hundred and seventy
seven seven thousand seven hundred and
seventy seven and so on so how can
almost all integers contain the digit 3.
so 23 contains the digit 3.
contains the digit 3.
9 million
so what about the numbers less than 10
numbers less than 10. how many numbers
less than 10 contain the digit three
it's just three isn't it yeah it's just
one of them right so one of those just
the number three itself so what's the
proportion of numbers well it's one out
of ten
so it's one tenth it's not point one
it's ten percent what's the next size up
let's look at numbers less than a
hundred we've got three
uh we've got 13
23 uh 43 53 63 73 83 93 you may have
noticed i skipped off the 30s there so
we've got 30 31 32 33 34 35 so i reckon
we've got
19. 19 out of 100 that's not point
one nine nineteen percent is what i'm
saying
so the percentage has gone up let's try
numbers less than a thousand
well we've got the 19 we said already
right but we've got all those numbers
again but with a one in front like it's
103 and 113 and then we get 200 and
something
we get 400 and something 500 600 700 800
and then we conclude all the 300s which
i skipped there so it's the 300 301 300
2000 right so it's 271.
what's the percentage
it's about 0.271
it's going up
now did you notice the trick that we
used for that last one i said you know
think of all the numbers with a one in
the front
it was the same copy but with the one in
the front with a two in the front and
there was all the 300 you can do this in
general
right
if say let's say the numbers containing
a digit three let's call that t for
three let's call these ten to the power
n right less than ten to the power n
so these are the numbers uh containing
a digit three less than 10 to the power
n
if you want to find the next one and
that's going to be 10 000.
you take the last your previous number
times it by 9 and add on
10 to the power n and you can find the
next number you can do that so that will
be
the next one we're looking for
so there's a little formula there so
let's do it
all right then i'm going to use my
calculator so
times 271
plus a thousand
and i get that number
three thousand
four hundred and thirty nine what's the
proportion
it's about naught point three four
three it's going up all the time about
thirty four percent now it's going up
all the time in fact
there's a nice way to work out
uh
how many numbers they're going to be
with a three
imagine if i was allowed to write my
numbers like this right with zeros
so that would be a zero
but with all these zeros this is a four
digit number so here's another one
right
and here's another one
how many four digit
numbers are there
it's actually 10 to the power 4. 10
choices there 10 choices there 10
choices 10 choices how many of them
don't have a 3
well if i'm not allowed to use 3 then i
only have 9 choices for that place
nine choices for that place nine choices
for that place nine choices for that
place so that would be nine to the power
four
if you want to find out
how many integers that contain the digit
three
it is
10 to the power n
minus 9 to the power n
so these are all my n digit numbers
minus the ones that don't contain a 3.
the proportion then it's going to be
this thing
divide by
just 10 to the n
so it's this
and what is that proportion
10 to the n divided by 10 to the n is 1
minus 9 to the n divided by 10 to the n
here's another way to write that 9 10
to the n
that's the proportion that contain
a digit three
and what does what happens well this is
this gets really really big
this fraction gets smaller and smaller
and smaller and it will go
to
one
that will disappear it will barely be
worth mentioning
and that is one so it goes to one
we say as n gets big so this is getting
closer and closer to one minus zero as
that gets closer to zero
as it gets big
this gets closer and closer to one minus
zero so the whole thing is going towards
one hundred percent
one hundred percent of numbers contain
the digit
three and this is the proper technical
definition of when i said almost all
numbers contain
the digit 3. almost all sounds like a
wishy-washy vague expression but in
mathematics it has a proper meaning it
means that the proportion is going
towards 100
as you get more and more numbers
would it be equally true to say
almost all numbers contain the number
five that would be equally true and you
can do the exact same thing to say
almost all numbers contain a 5.